تقوم
[الموسيقى]
بفعل
ما أردنا فعله حقًا هو التفكير في
المساحات التي يمكن أن تستجيب
للاحتياجات أثناء تغيرها
وللناس مع التغيرات الديموغرافية ، لذا يجب
أن يكون لكل شيء نفكر
فيه حياة مستقبلية سواء  هذا
متحرك
أو يتم إعادة استخدامه فقط
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن ما قد يحدث هو أن هذه
المباني التي تراها من
حولنا ستبدأ بالفعل في
الانفتاح وسنتنفس ، وسوف يصبح اللون الأخضر
أكثر عن الطبيعة
وأقل  حول الخرسانة والزجاج ،
فتخيل إذا كان مبنى من
إطار خرساني بسيط ،
فقد يتم إزالة أجزاء منه
ويمكن استبدال هذه الأجزاء
بمساحات خضراء سكنية ليتم
وضعها في
مباني المكاتب في هذا الطابق لتكون هنا حديقة
للتسوق هنا.  هنا
مستشفى هنا وبعد ذلك يمكن أن يتغير كل ذلك
بمرور الوقت
[موسيقى]
ما يقود المدن الذكية هو
فكرة عن الاستدامة
حتى يعرف الطريق متى تكون ساعة الذروة
في اتجاه ما
وفي اتجاه آخر ،  تحديد عدد
الممرات التي تسير في هذا
الاتجاه والتي ستعرف وقت ذروة الطلب على
الكهرباء ، وبالتالي فإنها ستغلق
أنظمة التبريد الخاصة بها وتشغيلها
في الليل فقط عندما يكون هناك طلب أقل
، وإعادة
صنع الأشياء التي لدينا بالفعل من
حولنا  كن أفضل
أعتقد أنها إحدى الفرص التي
لدينا وشيء أنا متحمس له حقًا
في المستقبل